et du tennis au roller oket à présent
les chocs d'élancour qui jouit encore ce
weekend oui il jouit ce weekend j'en
parlais en début de d'émission les chocs
font font un bon début de saison et pour
en parler avec nous sur ce plateau
Benjamin Ferrand l'entraîneur de
l'équipe première bonsoir à vous bonsoir
voez ben on fait un bon début de saison
cette année avec deux victoires d'un but
d'écart mais puis là ce weekend petite
défaite malheureusement chez nous voilà
parce que on fait une bonne première
mi-temps on 2-0 et une deuxème mi-temps
où on prend 4-1 et c'est un coup d'arrêt
justement cette défaite j'ai j'ai cru
comprendre qu' avait une défaillance
physique surtout en deuxième mi-temps
c'est ça montre un peu le manque de
rythmeou ben on gagne on gagne nos deux
premières sur un but d'écart et là aussi
on perd sur un but d'écart donc on est
vraiment très juste c'est dire qu'on
peut pas se permettre de de faire une
deuxième mi-temps comme on a fait sur ce
match là on est vraiment en dessous on
subit l'impact physique le roller HCK
c'est un sport qui le petit frère du
hocky sur glace donc c'est un sport qui
demande vraiment du défi physique et là
on a été vraiment en dessous sur cette
deuxème mi-temps et c'est aussi un sport
qui demande beaucoup de cardio en
général parce que il y a très peu de
pause entre entre les phases donc du
coup c'est vrai que dès qu'on a une
petite défaillance physique comme là
dimanche malheureusement ça se ressent
tout de suite au niveau du score euh oui
oui oui surtout que nous on était deux
lignes plus deux attaquants et l'équipe
d'averse avait plus de trois lignes à
proposer parce qu'on est ça c'est on
c'est un St mon tourne on reste pas on
reste pas tout le mat sin peu trop
difficile ouais et voilà donc et là ça
va être dur pour le moral justement pour
se relancer lorsqu'on débute très très
bien la saison et que là il y a vous avz
superbe match non je pense que je pense
que on est on est lucide aussi
c'est-à-dire que on a perdu deux très
bons joueurs qui étaient nos deux
meilleurs buteurs qui étaient des jeunes
joueurs qui sont partis pour des raisons
professionnelles et scolaires
euh et la chance qu'on a c'est qu'on a
eu un très bon gardien là qui est venu
en début de saison donc ça qui nous
sauve pas mal la baraque mais il faut
qu'on élucide sur notre jeu et donc là
il va falloir vraiment travailler le
physique je crois est notre est not le
point important qu'il va falloir
travailler pour vraiment continuer sur
cette saison et alors sur cette saison
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est toujours la
montée c'est les play-off l'objectif
c'est se qualifier en play-off et
ensuite espérer aller le plus loin
possible sur cette phase et alors on en
parlait un petit peu avant l'antenne il
y a eu des changements à
l'intersaison Oui au niveau des
structures vous avez vous axez un peu
plus sur la formation maintenant c'est
ça alors il y a toujours une formation
qui a été qui qui a été faite au niveau
des jeunesses et là-dessus faut
remercier did grosay qui a fait ce
travail là en amont et qui est aussi
partie du club et moi l'an dernier
j'étais entraîneur gen l'équipe N3 et
c'est un dossier qu'on m'a qu'on a eu la
gentillesse de me confier et et on
essaie cette année vraiment de
d'inscrire les les les
jeunes dans la compétition nationale
parce qu'on les avait inscrit dans une
compétition un petit peu parallèle l'an
dernier grâce à une petit goû au ha
niveau tout de suite un peu c'est ça
voilà en fait V là ils sont vraiment
inscrits sur le championnat qui va les
amener après aussi comme nous sur des
play-offs au niveau national pour jou
vraiment la compétition nationale et et
c'est vous qui prenez en charge les
jeunes cette anné VO c'est moi qui
prends en charge le la jeunesse cette
année et alors les les prochaines dates
importantes pour les chocs il y a le
championnat évidemment mais il y a
d'autres objectifs ou pas euh ben pour
les pour les chocs il y a on a aussi un
match de Coupe de France qui va tomber
ce weekend le weekend du du du 4
novembre en plein milieu des vacances de
la tousin reçoit à domicile rissoringis
en National 2 et donc match compliqué à
la
baseion comp nousavons pas forcément
d'objectifs important sur la Coupe de
France parce qu'on sait qu'il y a des
équipes beaucoup plus fortes que nous là
c'est vraiment pour pour faire jouer les
joueurs qui ne peuvent pas jouer sur la
saison nationale 3 et et voilà et puis
pour la jeunesse continuer à à les faire
progresser au sein au sein de au sein de
l'Entente et au sein du championnat
merci beaucoup Benjamin d'être venu ce
soir sur le plateau merci pour ce point
sur le roller roqueet quelques quelques
inf information encore deux dernières
informations Tony deux petites
informations tout d'abord au
championnats départementaux de
gymnastique rythmique qui se sont
déroulé ce weekend du côté de
Rambouillet le club de morpa et lancour
a une nouvelle fois monopolisé les
podiums le matin en compétition fédérale
comme au niveau national l'après-midi
prochaine étape les championnats
régionaux en février 2013 et puis autre
résultat peut-être du basket oui du
basket elles sont inarrêtables ce sont
les joueuses de l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles qui se sont imposé à Bresse
sur le score de 57 à 48 les joueuses
Guinois sont toujours invaincus et
restent en tête seul en tête de leur
poule de National 2 et comme il y a
beaucoup de résultats on peut aussi dire
quand handball féminin nouvelle défaite
pour la S Montini le Bretonneux face à
Fleury Loiret 32 à 26ou la saison risque
d'être très compliquée pour les les
joueur de la SMB merci Anthony pour ce
point sur le sport et puis cette autre
information qui concerne le gymnase
chantoal Maui à Mani les Hamo le 11
octobre dernier le ha vent c'est àessé
sur environ 50 m une expertise est en
cours en attendant le gymnase est fermé
jusqu'à nouvelle on passe à présent à la
dernière partie de cette édition du 78
une rencontre avec Yaya Siku Dianka il
est écrivain conseiller municipal à
Montini le Bretonneux il est sur ce
plateau